I was just at the live action Gala great  pro-life organization over the weekend  and they had an amazing statistic that  they've figured out through their own  internal research which is that when  peop people who are pro-choice are  presented with their information 19 of  those people change their views in the  pro-life Direction just by seeing the  pictures and the stories and the facts  the reality you're saying it's almost  one in five and it's because people just  don't really know what an abortion looks  like what it really means and I think  when it comes to transgenderism people  don't realize that gender affirming  surgery means you hack off little girls  forearms and you hack off parts of their  calves and you construct a fake meaty  disgusting pseudogenital and it's so  ghastly it's out of the most dystopian  novel if you just show people what that  is it's not going to be one in five who  changed their opinion it's going to be  four and five it might be even more